hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the TCC the top chess engine
competition Superfinal it's again a
alesh time versus stockfish and we said
that we were gonna cover another game
where perhaps the result will be a bit
different than in the previous game but
maybe it won't so we'll just have to
wait and see
so here Ali has the white pieces and
let's just check out the game so we have
e 4 e 6 by stockfish the French defense
and no I did not choose this game just
because black goes for the French
defense here we have d4 d5 and Knight to
c3 so a pretty standard stuff Knight to
f6 and now II five advancing the ponder
steinitz variation we have Knight back
to d7 and f4 now
cementing his pawn as of course white is
expecting an attack on the center with
c5 which is what black plays Knight of
three defending d4 also developing a
nice to see 16 pretty increasing the
pressure on d4 Bishop to e3 adding yet
another defender while developing and
now once black trades we have seek
address on d4 Knight captures and Bishop
to c5 Queen to d2 and here black just
castles you'd have to be careful about
going something like Queen to b6 it does
seem like it increases the pressure even
further but here what has the very
tricky Knight to a4 which attack is both
the Queen and the bishop and now if
Queen before you just trade captures
captures for example King characters
here and mountain knight recaptures on
c5 and you don't win a piece with Knight
captures on c6 while you do open up a
discovery here because the black has
this in between check and only then
black will recapture the piece so you
have to be careful about things like
that but okay even even if you don't
capture on c6 you can play a four and
you will have a slightly better position
you still have the bishop repair and the
position is perfectly fine so black
instead just castles
still decides what to do with the Queen
and we have queenside castle by ally and
now again we have opposite side castles
and it's gonna be a race white will
attack on the Kings side and the black
will try to attack on the Queen side
with a6 preparing b5 and b4 and nice the
beef
now attacking the bishop while offering
a trade on e3 so black decides that the
bishop will still be a useful piece
retreats it with not there obviously
Bishop the back to e7 and now H for
preparing h5 and h6 now this has all
been played before even in human chess
with b5 by black preparing b4 also
wanting to trade off some pieces night
this night can come to e5 and then to c4
also pretty a pretty often idea with h5
and now there is one game that redo
disposition from 2006 Marcos rocker vs.
Victor elders were b4 was played right
away but here we have nice - a 5 and
this is now a new move in the position
so as I move 13 we have a completely new
game so let's see what what happens next
with h6
I you want to pull that bone all the way
create some dark square weaknesses we
have g6 by black and now kink the beef
uh I think to be one just a nice
prophylactic move a long long time ago
grandmasters agree that this was always
a good idea not only as black has a
semi-open C file for the rook but also
black still has the dark square bishop
so if the position opens up you can
always find yourself on the wrong side
of some tricky ideas so it's better
better just play right away King to be
one Knight to c4
now either you will allow black to have
this monster night on c4 or you will
eliminate it almost always white
eliminates it so Bishop captures on c4 d
captures and C for now and now as the
Knights under attack Knight to d4 with B
for further pushing on the Queen side
and the Knight to e4 and now c3 so
already we can see that stockfish is on
the attack with Queen to d3 and the now
comes Queen to c7
there's no point in capturing you can
always do this and you can be pretty
sure that white will never recapture or
play b3 and it would be pretty pretty
bad and you can just you know create
some very very nasty ideas so nice the
d6 by Ali and now what's the idea behind
Knight to d6 well now White has a
monster night and if you can remove it
it would be great but you can't for
example if Bishop captures pawn captures
and now Queen captures you have the
problem of night
to the f5 who offering the Queen trade
and now if Queen captures on d3 which is
pretty much your only good option first
you're gonna play nice the e7 check came
to h8 only move and now rook captures on
d3 and here you cannot prevent both
threats of Knight captures on c8
followed by rook captures on d7 and also
the threat of Bishop d4 which would
result either in in in a mating attack
or or severe material loss for black so
you have to prevent Bishop to d4 and now
it's just winning a piece Knight
captures rook captures in the rook
capture Sun d7 winning for white so
after this for example like we said if
you capture on d6 captures and now you
don't capture let's say go Queen to b7
still doesn't help you all that much
because now this dying and e6 white
opened up this diagonal and it's just
much better for white you can even play
captures captures night b3 you block the
attack and now black is gonna have
pretty much an impossible task of
defending the position along the dark
squares you don't even have time to
start your own attack on the Queen side
it's okay after Knight to d6 of course
dr. Fischer does not allow such a
position to rise a rather see capture
some b2 now and now comes Queen to e4
going after the rookin e8 but it's very
hard to decide what to do with the rook
for example if you move it to a7 you go
under the mask of the bishops you don't
want to allow something like that if you
go to be 8000 long nice to see six and
now you either lose the bishop here with
Czech or if you want to defend that
somehow well not there but like move it
then you have to give up the exchange on
b8 so here we have Knight b6 just
defending that rook an a8 but this
allows a white a very interesting
combination so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this sneaky
idea white played in this position while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on you know going
forward within the night and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
its Knight d2 b5 it's a very tricky idea
where you offer a knight
the queen is under attack and
doesn't have a better move other than
capturing the night because whatever you
play the shop capture some v6 is coming
and that removes the defender of the
rook on a eight
so here stockfish captured an eye with a
Tetris and b5 Bishop characters and b6
and of course you cannot capture because
Queen captures rook so Queen to b8
getting the Queen out of the way and now
Bishop back to c5 just cementing that
night over there and also preparing
Bishop captures on b4 which is very
important once the bishop gets this be
Foursquare then you can just play a
three and you're perfectly safe on the
on the Queen side here stock which
continue special to d7 you want to get
the other rookie into the game as well
but your character son before as as we
planned and now rook to a6 we have
looked h3 a very nice roof lifts from
here this rope can join as just doubling
up the rocks along the d5 but also it
will help help out with the defense of
the Queen side once this pawn comes to
a3 it will just be an additional
defender to the Queen side pawns and now
it's it's not easy for blacks to
continue this attack like we said any
any threats along the a file will just
be met with a three there's nothing to
look for there so here our stock which
offers the Queen trade and Ally accepts
with Queen captures this allows the
other rook to go here create some
threats along the a file but now just a
three and you are perfectly safe here
with Bishop the c6 stockfish now
activates the bishop on this beautiful
diagonal but now g4 and now as you don't
want to you don't want to wait for
for--why to complete the setup of his
pieces to get this rope to d3 to push
maybe f5 here to bust open the the King
side here stock which plays f6 and okay
with each captures on f6 now this bishop
also gets this beautiful diagonal and
now rook to e3 going after the e6 pawn
bishop to d5 defending and now g5 first
pushing the bishop back with Bishop to
h8 and now look back to d3 and here
looked a for stock which now creates a
threat for example if white makes a
silly move something like rook to e1
just waiting to see what happens then
the threat was Bishop rook actress unn
unn before just before example phone
captured okay one is mate because the
the
the b2 point is defended so here we have
c3 now making sure that if captures then
the C pawn can capture back and now rook
to b8 and buy stock fish so what do you
play here
the problem with capturing on b5 is a
Bishop c4 and not something well not
immediately as now now the rookies on d8
but in most of the lines you will not be
able to capture it due to the due to
this Bishop to c4 idea here if you
capture it it's okay white can go after
this point but now Bishop the e4 pins it
as the King is still on b1 so that's the
idea here
so after this rook to d8 move you can't
go after the pawn right away we have
nice to b7 now a very interesting idea
kicking the rook away from the d8 square
and also you cannot capture it because
of rook captures rook so here
rook the c8 and getting broke out of the
attack and now King captures and b2 so
not really getting rid of the pawn that
pawn wasn't doing all that much but you
no longer have your your well King and
b1 so it will not be able to be under
attack now we look back to a 8 now
getting this rook to just to a 8 and now
Knight back to d6 attacking this rope
once again and now black really has
problems now the king is on b2 and there
is no Bishop to c4 to win the exchange
here so how do you prevent Knight
characters on b5 well other than just
moving the rope for example if ruk to d8
then you can capture it Knight captures
on b5 and you don't have Bishop to c4 as
your rook would be hanging on d8 so
that's a problem on the other hand if
you play something like rook see to b8
now you're no longer here but now you
have different problems white will now
just waste a move here rook the d2 and
now you you still have to play something
you can't go to the D file we already
said that all of these squares are
covered by the knight f8 is well going
under the mask of the bishop so here you
have to play something like rook to e7
but now White's idea is f5 and f5 is
just extremely strong you
recapture with this because the bishop
Falls who would have to play G captors
and all night captures on f5 for example
captures captures and here we have just
a position where white is up upon but in
a much more active position with better
pieces and this will be winning for
white especially when when an engine
plays the same game and lastly but not
leastly after this idea of attacking the
rook if you play something like rook the
c7 it's the same white will just make
waste a move rook Wandy to force black
to move something and after rook CTA 7
for example as now these scores are
covered by the knight again you play f5
and it's pretty much the same and
getting captures captures characters
characters and white will be what will
be able to prevail here so after Knight
to d6 we have rook to f8 you know out of
the for evils choose to choose the
lesser one but there is no lesser evil
here as you will lose another pawn so
nice captures and b5 but you know even
in your own games before you capture a
point you have to check all of the
possibilities so the rook is now under
attack you don't have time for something
like this look back the c8 and not just
Knight back to d6 so you retrieved with
the knight to this very nice square
while now being up two points so rook
the f8 once again with nice to b5
repeating once this is now move 40 I
don't know if they reach time control
have unnatural got that as I didn't read
it but seems like a reasonable thing to
do as as there's there's a repetition of
moves so maybe they do have time control
but I can't confirm that room F back to
c8 and now as alleys up two points not
interested in a draw with Knight back to
d4 now we have to find another really
active square for this night and also
there is the point of the week east
exponent so there's that so King to f7
night to see to now Bishop to c6 and the
now comes Knight step III with Bishop
back Bishop to b5 attacking the rook
rook to d6 and the now comes in Bishop
to a for attacking the other rook rook
the d3 and now rook to e8 just waiting
to see what white will do Knight to g4
now
again Rema nuvaring the night King to
King back to g8 and now Knight to e5
with Russia back to b5 attacking the
rook look the d4 now both rooks are on
dark squares and all of your other
pieces are on dark score so you don't
have to worry about this light squared
bishop annoying you
Bishop to a4 and now finally c4 starting
to push the past pawn and now you have
to we have to ask ourselves can you
eliminate the night here your Bishop is
pretty useless on a trade I mean it's on
a lovely diagonal but with the knight on
e5 it's a dark square
you don't really there's no way that
that night is ever moving so we have to
check is it possible to remove it F
captures and now for example rook to e7
but you will win the e6 pawn look at for
your planning rook to f6 and just pick
up the pawn and if rook to f7 you still
play rook to f6 and if white it doesn't
want to allow this capture you will have
to capture but now this is completely
winning for white you're just gonna move
the roof to the seventh rank control the
seventh rank push f7 for example and
that's that's just it
so here after c4 we have rook eat the b8
just trying something waiting for for
black for white to make a move and rook
captures on e6 as we already seen there
was no way of guarding this pawn we have
looked at a seven and now King to c3
getting the King to a safer Square rook
the c8 and now pink the d3 we have
looked the beep so that's the a rook
rook to b8 and now look the d5 we have
looked back to see it and now rook eat a
d6 doubling up on the D file rook to e8
and now rook to b6 we're up the c7 and
now Bishop to d6 so taking away almost
all of the squares from blacks pieces we
have looked back the a7 and now you
could push c5 right away but Ali wants
to keep everything in order to place
King - D - King - D - probably with the
idea if you see five right away there's
Bishop d1 maybe opening up a discovered
attack to the rook here but playing
Quinta D - this Bishop has no squares so
none of the squares this Bishop can use
are available as now the King covers
both c2 and the d1 so this Bishop
now a very bishop you know again this is
no way to treat your bishop
so we have looked the c8 now comes a
rook to d3 first before pushing the C
pawn again probably just the further
improving the position before deciding
to push this is just the you know
extreme preparation before you go for
the pawn push rook rook C back to a 8
and now comes finally c5 with Bishop
captures on e5 black cannot afford to
wait any longer Bishop captures on e5
and now rook to c8 and after playing
rock to c8 it was in this position that
stockfish resigned the game or as we
like to remind ourselves both both
engines agreed that the evaluation is
more than minus 10 and the game just
ended so your ear up 3 points here
there's no real way of black to even
play this even you would win the second
stockfish there's there's no you know no
question about it but there's even no
threat of capturing the c5 one if you
just play something like rook rook d6
and if the pawn is captured you just win
the game on the spot rugby it checking
if 7 look if 6 checking has to move and
now Bishop d6 will win that sad rook
that captured the pawn so nothing
nothing to be done there so I have to
look to see 8 the game ended on move 60
and a very nice victory for for this new
neural network engine Elish time so like
I said I will put two links in the
description below one will be where you
will be able to follow this 100 match
100 games match contest between the two
of them and the other will be if you
want to read a bit more about Alec Stein
about the creator's about well just
everything you can read about this new
neural network engine yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank your brain Schmidt Alan
Wang Kathleen Northrop teres cardiac and
rain you Lou if my translator is not
deceiving me for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon still
continuing
to check up on your suggestions waiting
for my book to arrive so we can finish
off the cup of Blanco Sagar conclusion
and I have some interesting stuff
prepared for you so hope you will enjoy
that as well
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day